[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Lindsey is
going to be talking to us today
about the interaction between
food and our emotions.
And I'm super excited
for her to be here.
She's been featured on
"Oprah," "The Lisa Oz Show."
She's been in "Real Simple."
So we're very, very
lucky to have her.
She lives in Pittsburgh
with her husband
and her pup, Winnie Cooper,
who is exceptionally cute.
And today we're going to hear
Lindsey talk to all of us
about some of the
concepts in her book.
We are going to have
a Q&A at the end.
So start thinking
about your questions.
And there is a Dory for
everybody who is watching
the livestream,
Go/LindseySmith-Dory.
So go ahead and
add your questions.
And for those of you live,
if you ask a question,
we're going to be
giving you away a book.
So start thinking
about questions.
And I'm super excited to
welcome Lindsey to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
LINDSEY SMITH: Thank you.
Hey, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here.
And we get to fruit
and veggie it up
via pantsuit and the stage.
So we got to bring a little
fruit and veggie life to Google
today.
I want to start off by
just telling you a story
and how all of this came
together for me with food,
and mood, and really, how
I became the Food Mood Girl
and why I care about this.
In 2011, I graduated
from nutrition school.
And as a fresh
graduate, I was so
excited to bring nutrition
knowledge to everyone,
everywhere.
I mean, I was so into
healthy living, and juicing,
and eating right.
I mean, I was eating quinoa
before quinoa was cool,
when it was like $15 a pound.
You know what I mean?
You could only find it at
certain specialty stores.
And with this, I decided
that I felt the need
to educate friends and family.
You know what I mean?
And by educating, being like,
oh, what's on your plate there?
Ooh, pizza, again?
What are you eating?
I cared so much about
health that I wanted people
to have this knowledge.
I wanted people to get
excited about eating
fruits and vegetables,
and eating quinoa,
and all of these things.
And I had this judgmental
approach, though.
And all of this came to a head
in the Pittsburgh airport.
So let me tell you this story.
It was right after I graduated.
I was on my way to a
nutrition conference.
So I had just got out
of Western Pennsylvania,
the mecca of meat and potatoes.
I don't know if anyone has
ever been to Pittsburgh before,
but we put fries on salad.
So I was like, oh, I'm going
to be with all of my nutrition
people, all of my health peeps.
There's going to be 5,000
of us at this conference.
We're going to be doing
kale shots off yoga mats.
It's going to get
real crazy up in here.
So I'm a recovering
Type A perfectionist.
So I go to the airport like 10
hours early, because I'm like,
am I going to-- you know,
I don't want to be late.
So I get to the airport early.
And I was like, you know what?
This would be a great time
to write a blog about the six
benefits of juicing kale and why
you need to do it in your life.
So I get to the airport
early, and I decided to write.
So I look over at this
little section in there.
And there was
probably 10 tables,
and no one was sitting there.
And I was like,
oh, this is great.
I'll go sit there.
This is perfect.
So I go.
I get my hot water.
And, of course, I bring my
own teabag wherever I go.
Because you can't
trust the airport tea.
And so I get my hot water.
I get my tea.
I set up this little
station for myself.
And I'm like, ah,
writing about kale.
This is so great.
So like 5, 10 minutes go by.
And all of a sudden, I
see people coming out
of this door in
this little section.
And I look up, and I see
it says, "Employees Only."
So I'm in this
employees only section.
I didn't realize that I was.
And I was like,
well, you know what?
I'm not being bothered.
To each his own.
It's all good.
I'll just stay here.
If someone kicks me
out, it'll be fine.
So another like 5,
10 minutes go by.
And this is early.
This is like 7 o'clock
in the airport.
And all of a sudden,
this woman comes out
of this door, and this--
I'm going to do the best
impression of her that I can.
She comes out.
She's on her cell phone.
And she's like, I
hate this place!
This place sucks!
F you!
Bah!
And I'm like, oh, my goodness.
I'm like, what is
wrong with this woman?
I'm like, does she not realize
I made a Feng shui thing here?
Like, this energy is just not
good for what I have going on.
But she's just, like, miserable.
And she comes out of the
employee only section.
I'm like, whatever.
She left.
I was like, OK, you
know, to each his own.
I'm going to go back
to writing about kale.
So another 5, 10 minutes go
by, and this woman comes back.
And this time, she had
a tray full of food.
And of all the other nine tables
she could sit, where do you
think she sat?
Directly in front of me.
But at this point, my computer
was blocking-- kind of
like blocking her.
But I'm sitting there, and
I'm like, she's in a bad mood.
She's miserable.
I was like, I kind of want
to know what she's eating.
Because remember, I cared.
I wanted to educate people.
So I was like, should I look?
Shouldn't I?
I was like, OK.
I'm going to look
what she's eating.
Because clearly she
was in a bad mood,
and I need to see what's
going on with her.
So my computer's up, right?
And I can't really see.
So I'm like-- all of
a sudden, you just
see my head peek
out from my computer
to try to get a glimpse
of what's on her tray.
And I could not make
this story up if I tried.
This was about 7:30
in the morning now.
On her tray, this woman had a
large Ben and Jerry's chocolate
milkshake.
Some people are like, oh,
isn't that considered kind
of a smoothie?
And I kind of want those
for breakfast myself.
As if that wasn't
enough, she then
had a large bowl of chocolate
ice cream with whipped cream
on top, right next
to the milkshake.
As if that wasn't
enough, she then
had a large omelette
with hash browns,
and she's just
pouring ketchup on it.
And this is at 7:30
in the morning.
And the health coach in
me is like, oh my god.
Does she not know
what she's doing?
Is she not knowing
that what she's eating
is directly affecting
how she's feeling?
And the reason why she
is coming out here,
and she's so miserable,
and she's flipping out
is because of all this food?
And I was so angry with her.
I was like, oh, I
want to tell her.
I want to tell her that
there's more out there for her.
But I was like,
Lindsey, you're going
with your nutrition peeps.
You're going to be with
them in a couple hours.
Just calm down, relax.
You're not trying
to get arrested.
So I was like, OK.
So I put some of the essential
oils or something on me
and was like, we're
going to calm down.
So then, 5, 10 more minutes go
by, and I hear some shuffling.
And I'm like, do I look?
Don't I look?
But then I'm like, I'm
kind of already invested.
I need to know what she's doing.
So again, peeking
around the computer.
At, like, 7:35,
7:40 in the morning,
this woman now pulls
out a lunchbox cooler.
I'm like, are you kidding me?
More food?
What could you possibly need?
And then I'm calculating it.
I'm like, you just ate 3,200
calories, 87 grams of sugar.
There's probably 87
chemicals in that milkshake.
And I'm getting so
upset with this woman.
I'm like, uhh.
So I'm like, OK, calm down.
But then she pulls out
her lunchbox cooler.
And I'm like, OK, I need
to see what she has in it.
And at like 7:40 in the morning,
this woman, on her tray,
pulls out five
prescription medications.
And one by one, she's slurping
them down with her chocolate
milkshake.
And at this point, I am
furious with this woman.
I'm like, oh my goodness.
Do you not realize
that what you're eating
is directly affecting
how you're feeling
and all of these medications--
you know, you wouldn't have
to take them if you would just
eat properly and--
you know, you-- oh, I
was just so frustrated.
I could not believe
that this was happening.
So at this point, I
put my laptop down.
I'm just looking at
her like, it is on.
But then I'm like, I'm not
really going to do anything.
[LAUGHS] But I was
like, it is on.
And I just couldn't believe
that someone could do that
to themselves, to eat
that way and then think
that the medication
was going to help.
So at this point, I was really
engrossed in this woman.
And I was just like, I
need to know everything
and what she's doing.
But I was like, just calm down.
So I was trying to
calm myself down.
But I just kept staring at her.
And then five more
minutes go by,
and then this is when
everything changed.
It's 7:30 in the airport.
And this woman pulls out her
lunchbox cooler once again.
And I'm like, more food?
More drugs?
What could you possibly need?
And at 7:45 in the airport, this
woman sits back in her chair.
She takes a sigh.
She looks at her food.
She looks at the tray.
She looks at the drugs.
And she looked
defeated, like the food,
and the drugs, and
all of that, just won.
She pushes her tray forward.
She grabs her lunchbox
cooler once again.
And in the middle
of the airport,
this woman opens up the cooler.
She lifts up her shirt, she
rubs herself with alcohol,
and she injects herself
with an insulin shot.
And at this point, I was no
longer mad at this woman.
I was no longer frustrated
with this woman.
I really was able,
in that moment,
to see a reflection
of my own self
and the trajectory of
the path that I was on.
I thought, what if, at
the end or the beginning
of the day, this woman--
the only thing she had
to make her feel better
was that chocolate milkshake?
She clearly didn't like her job.
She was irritated at
someone on the phone.
And what if that
was the only thing--
and if she was diagnosed
with something, being
diagnosed with any disease--
and I know personally--
is a challenge.
And it's something that
you need to work through.
And so when I
watched this woman,
I was at first so judgmental.
And I realized, you know,
she was no different than me
and I was no different than her.
The difference is I was able
to choose a different way
and to get on a healthier track.
Because when I was 12 years
old, I suffered from anxiety.
I was actually
hospitalized at age 12.
I was taken out of
school, put IVs in my arm.
And I too used food
to fill a comfort,
to fill a void that
I felt within myself,
my low self-esteem.
And so when I watched
her, I realized
I was no different than her.
And here I had been judging
people, judging my family,
judging my friends, judging this
stranger at the airport, when
really what I needed to start
to understand and foster
was real empathy and meeting
people where they are.
Because we don't know.
We don't know someone's life.
We don't know what
they're struggling with.
And it's meeting them where
they are and actually listening.
So this moment actually
changed the entire trajectory
of my career.
Because I was this crazy
judgmental person when
it came to food and nutrition,
thought I knew it all,
wanted to evangelize
everyone I met.
And what I realized is that
it's a lot deeper than that.
And so today I want
to share with you
some of these
principles that I've
learned, not only
in my own journey,
but through working with
people, and through seminars,
and through--
just hearing people's stories
when it comes to food.
And the first thing that I truly
believe when it comes to food
is that we were born
emotional eaters.
And I know that's kind
of a bold statement.
Because so many of us, when we
think of emotionally eating,
we think of the breakup
with the ice cream.
Or we think of a
stressful day at work,
and I want pizza, or
a burger, or fries.
And that is one aspect of it.
And it is a spectrum.
But our true being
are emotional eaters.
What does a baby, a newborn,
do when they're hungry?
They cry.
What did I do yesterday
when I was hungry?
I cried.
We're no different from that.
And so because I truly believe
that we're emotional eaters--
and I look at it as
really a positive thing.
I look at it as something
that we can learn from,
that we can foster that empathy
within others and in ourselves,
and learn more about ourselves
through realizing that.
Which brings me to my next
point, which is listening,
listening to your body.
So many times, we--
how many of us have ever
been on a diet before?
That's like everyone.
That's like 99.9% of
people in the world.
I really want to meet
the 0.01% person that's
never been on a diet.
But maybe you've done
the buddy system.
How many of you
have done the buddy
system, where you're like,
yeah, we're doing this together?
And we're going on this plan,
and it's going to be great.
And so maybe it's a partner,
or a friend, or a coworker.
And you decide to
get on this plan,
and you're all jazzed about it.
And you're checking
in with each other.
And you're like, yeah,
this is going great.
And week 1, right?
Week 1 is the big week.
It's like when you
start feeling better,
and you can start seeing.
And your friend is like,
oh, I'm just loving this.
This is so great.
I think I just lost three
pant sizes in one week.
This is incredible.
I have so much more energy.
And you're on the
scale, like, oh, my god.
Did I just gain weight?
Is that possible?
We're doing the
same exact thing!
And that's because every
body is so different.
And so I think that
it's great that there's
different diets and lifestyles.
But I think what
we need to do is
take that information from
it and learn to figure out
what our body needs
and what truly
is going to fuel our body.
Because they're
all so different.
A quick example of this.
When I first got into
health and nutrition,
we learned all the dietary
theories that there are,
pretty much.
And there's a lot of them.
And I was really big
into the blood type
diet and some different diets.
And I thought-- I was like, yes.
My body is meant
to be vegetarian.
This is what it is.
So I was a vegetarian for eight
years, and then I went vegan.
And about six months into
it, I got really sick.
I mean, I passed out
in the shower, sick.
And here I am this health
person, this health coach.
So it's like, yes, I eat fruits
and veggies, and I'm so great.
And here I was passing
out in my shower.
And it was not--
it was not one, a good look.
And two, it proved
against what I know now,
which is that we're
so bioindividual
and we're so all different.
And so when that happened,
I got really sick.
And then I was like, all of a
sudden, I was craving a burger.
That's all I wanted.
I was just like, I--
but my mind was so ingrained
in being in this one way,
not listening to my body,
being OK, this is what you are.
This is what you're doing.
It almost became part of who
I was, that I was vegetarian.
It was my label that I wanted
to wear and let everyone know.
And I wasn't actually listening.
And all of a sudden, I'm just
craving this and craving this.
So finally one day, I decided--
I told my husband.
I was like, I think
I need a burger.
Will you go with me?
It was a big deal.
I was like, we need to make
sure that it's grass-fed.
I need to know the cow's name.
I was like, we've really
got to be OK with this.
He was so excited.
He was like, yeah.
He's like, I can't wait
to get this on film.
And I'm like, oh my god.
So we go to this joint.
And I'm literally--
I kid you not.
I'm walking in like,
I hope no one sees me.
If they know that I'm--
I'm just getting a
veggie burger, guys.
And so I go, and I
order this cheeseburger.
And I eat it.
And I felt so much better,
instantly so much better.
And what I realized is I
was definitely lacking iron.
There were certain things in
my diet that I wasn't getting
and that I needed.
And it was in that instance
that I was like, you know,
listening to your
body is so important.
Because we put
labels on everything.
And we want to constantly label
things, including our diet,
and put ourselves
in these boxes.
But our bodies change.
Every six months, your
taste buds are changing.
And your body is constantly
evolving, and adapting,
and changing.
And so you need to
be open and to listen
so that you can really
see what your body needs.
And when it comes to cravings,
like that red meat craving--
oftentimes, we look also at
cravings as a really bad thing.
We're like, oh,
I'm craving this.
I'm so bad.
Cravings are actually
the gatekeepers
to let our bodies know
what they really need.
And the more that you listen,
the more that you understand,
and the more that you can truly
foster a closer relationship
with you and your body, you
won't ever have to diet again.
Because you'll know what
your body needs, when--
at what times.
And you'll be able to
adapt, and flow, and change,
rather than being so restrictive
and so intense about it.
So the next point, when it
comes to food, and mood,
and emotions, and
this whole concept,
is not only listening
to your body,
but also feeling your feelings.
So many of us--
the reason why we
are quick to grab a Snickers
bar, quick to grab chips,
or whatever it may be, is
because we don't actually
stop and allow ourselves
to feel whatever feeling
that we're feeling.
And we're just quick to
go to the next thing.
A quick-- another
little story about this.
This was in 2014.
This one day, it was a
rainy Saturday afternoon.
And all of a sudden, I
got this intense craving
for a grilled cheese.
And I'm not talking like
those highbrow grilled cheeses
from, like, San Francisco,
you know, where they're like--
have all these crazy ingredients
on them, and they're like $25.
I'm talking I wanted Wonder
Bread with butter and Land
O'Lakes cheese.
That's what I wanted.
And so I almost--
I had my keys in my hand.
I'm ready to go out the door.
And then I just stopped.
And I said, what's
actually going on here?
Let me just sit with
this for a minute.
Let me just feel
And so what I had realized is
I had this moment of clarity
and this moment of being
able to feel what I actually
was feeling.
And it was grief.
And it was sadness.
Because my dad
passed away in 2012.
And when I was a kid on
rainy Saturday afternoons,
he would make me
a grilled cheese,
and we would watch copious
amounts of "Unsolved
Mysteries," which,
as a seven-year-old--
I was like seven
at the time-- like,
the parenting choice of
letting your child watch--
you know, that's besides
the point-- letting
me watch "Unsolved Mysteries."
But the point is I was--
in that moment, when
I was craving that grilled
cheese, the raininess,
the Saturday
afternoon-- all of that
brought the feeling
of being with my dad.
And so that's what
I really wanted.
That's what I was
really missing.
And so at that point,
I had a decision.
I was like, well, I can
eat the grilled cheese,
eat it, appreciate it I
can make an upgraded one.
I can-- but then
I was like, huh.
I wonder if "Unsolved Mysteries"
is anywhere online right now.
And I did find it
on Amazon Prime.
And I was like, I'm going to
watch "Unsolved Mysteries"
this rainy afternoon,
and really honor and feel
that feeling in that way.
And let me just tell you,
"Unsolved Mysteries,"
as an adult, is a horrible show.
I was like, why was I
allowed to watch this?
This is so bad.
They actually do
these reenactments.
It's the whole thing.
I was like, oh, my goodness.
But it actually made me laugh.
And feeling that feeling
and going with that--
it actually ended up
providing me with nutrients
and providing me with a sense
that the grilled cheese never
could.
And that's because I
allowed myself to feel.
So listening to your body,
feeling your feelings--
and, you know, the
last thing with this
is to prescribe as necessary.
And what I mean by that
is food can greatly
help with your emotions.
And your emotions can dictate
the food choices that you eat.
And so I think it's
important to understand
how both play into your life
so that you can truly see what
you may need at certain times.
For example, in my new
book, "Eat Your Feelings,"
I actually map out some
of the different emotions.
So for example, if
you're sad, your body
really wants serotonin.
And it can find that
in carbs and sugar,
basically, so pizza and cookies.
So when we're sad, our initial
quick knee-jerk reaction
is to go to the
pizza and the cookies
because it's going to
give us that quick fix.
However, long term, what your
body needs-- like I said,
it wants the serotonin.
And so incorporating foods
such as nuts and seeds--
is just one example
that actually help
your body produce serotonin--
can give you longer term
benefits, rather than
that quick fix.
Some of the other
ones that I have--
if you're sad, if you're
stressed, grounding foods.
When you're stressed
out, usually it's
all in your head
and your upper body.
And so eating foods
that are grounding,
that are lower to the Earth,
can actually help ground
you, so things like
carrots and sweet potatoes.
So if you're sad, stressed.
If you're tired, you
want something energizing
and uplifting, so
citrus, or leafy greens,
or something like that.
And if you're
hangry, when you're
so hungry that you become
angry, like I do, many days--
I always say that.
You don't care if it was made
by Julia Child or a child,
you just need food
and need it now.
So to avoid being
hangry, though, you
could fuel up on things like
healthy fats and proteins
earlier in the day, so you don't
get those 2 PM hanger shakes.
Sad, stressed, tired, bored--
or hangry-- and bored.
If you're bored,
again, that's something
that your brain actually needs
energy when you're bored.
And so if you're a bored
eater, where you're just like,
oh, I have nothing else
to do, chips sound great.
And then you're like, well,
now I need something sweet.
So this sounds great.
But really what you
need is something
like a healthy fat, something
to truly fuel your brain so
that you feel energized and that
you feel active in your brain.
So like I said,
listening to your body,
feeling your feelings,
prescribing food as necessary--
all of these things are
this really intricate dance
that your body will work with
you on, if you choose to listen
and if you choose to really
understand the deeper
connections that the food
and mood plays into it.
So to put this in full circle
and to wrap all this together,
I want to read a quick
little thing from my book.
It's called the "Food
Mood Girl Femifesto."
And this kind of
wraps up everything
that we just talked about.
Your body is a magical machine.
It's like a computer
program specifically for you
and only you.
Cherish it.
Trust it.
Treat it with respect.
Talk to your body
like you would talk
to a really cute dog,
except not in public,
because that might be weird.
Take time to eat
really good real food.
That includes leafy
greens and a cookie.
Eat everything with love.
Cook everything with love.
Love is always the
secret ingredient.
Ask questions.
Be open to growth.
Ask more questions.
Be kind to yourself and others.
Release judgments.
Challenge conventional norms.
Do something that scares you.
Listen more, react less.
Laugh your ass off, preferably
in the company of others,
but by yourself is cool too.
Listen to your gut.
Always listen to your gut.
It's right 99% of the time.
Embrace your body's unique size.
Know that it will
change and evolve.
It might grow and shrink, but
it still loves you all the same.
And above all, love yourself.
Like, really, truly
love yourself.
Celebrate and appreciate
yourself daily.
And remember, this is the
only body in life you have.
So love it up the best you can.
And when all else
fails, just Google it.
I had to, guys.
I had to.
Sorry, I just had to.
I had to throw something
cheesy in there.
But I appreciate you
all for being here
and for listening to this.
And I think we're going
to open it up to a Q&A,
so if you have any
specific questions.
I know we have some coming in.
Love to answer it for you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, thanks.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Thank
you so much, Lindsey.
LINDSEY SMITH: Thank you.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE:
So we have a couple
of questions on the Dory.
So we can take Dory questions
and also live questions.
And as a reminder,
we definitely are
excited to give away some books.
So we want to definitely
take it away with questions.
So we'll start with one
from the Dory, which
I think is really, really
relevant to what we were just
talking about.
So it's an anonymous
question, and it says,
how do you suggest
combating boredom eating?
It's so easy.
I Google to stop by our
micro kitchens, which you've
witnessed, for a snack, when
all you need is a break,
or to make food when you
just want to watch TV.
LINDSEY SMITH: Well, why don't
you take the break or watch TV?
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Yeah.
That's a very valid answer.
LINDSEY SMITH:
Sometimes, what I find
is we overthink things when
it comes to stuff like this,
and health, and nutrition.
Even something like that,
we know what we want to do.
But what is stopping us?
And I think that's where it's
stopping and really feeling
our feelings, being able to say,
wait, do I just need a break?
Yeah, let me go
get some fresh air.
Or yeah, I just want to
veg and watch TV tonight.
And that's OK.
Sometimes we think we need
to be doing something more.
But we need to allow
ourselves to have
those moments of the breaks.
And I think that
that's sometimes
why we gravitate towards
food, because it makes us feel
like we're doing something.
It's like, well, I
accomplished a lot today
by eating three bags of Doritos.
It gives us a sense
of purpose, almost.
But really, we
just need a break.
And so allowing yourself
to have that, I think,
is really important.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Yeah.
And I think that's super
relevant for Googlers,
because a lot of
us work nonstop.
And so that reminder of
just letting yourself
take that time is
really helpful.
LINDSEY SMITH: And
oftentimes, when
you allow yourself to step
away and take that break,
you'll find that you're
more productive later on.
You find that you think that you
have a million things going on
and that you need to do all
of these things and have them.
But if you just allow yourself,
then your energy is more clear,
your mind is more clear, and
you can go into that situation
and probably even do
it at a faster rate
than if you would just try
to power through and struggle
through it.
I know that from
personal experience.
Writing a book is not
an easy thing to do.
You're like, oh,
snacks and laundry.
When you start doing laundry
instead of writing a book,
you know that's like really bad.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: I
think we've all been there.
Maybe not the writing the book.
But the doing laundry to
procrastinate anything else.
LINDSEY SMITH: Yes.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Do we want
to have any live questions?
We have a mic in the
back, if you don't mind,
so that everybody can hear you.
LINDSEY SMITH: It's so official.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE:
It really is.
AUDIENCE: So this is kind of
similar to the question that
was just asked.
But I realize I
almost never eat fruit
because it takes me a long
time to prepare it, to cut it.
And if I want to
get a snack, it's
just easier to grab a
bag of chips, as opposed
to taking five minutes
to cut and wash a fruit.
So what tips do you
have to feel more
motivated to eat healthier?
LINDSEY SMITH: So
a couple of things.
One of the key things in
the book that I talk about
is everyone says you
are what you eat.
That's like, you
I believe you are what you chop.
It's true.
Because you're
like, I don't like--
it takes me five
minutes to chop.
And so that's what stops
you from doing that.
Because it's easier to
grab the other thing.
Or how many of you have
ever tried to cut an onion
and you're still figuring out?
You're like, wait,
which way do I
turn it to get slices
versus dices, right?
And so that's what
stops us from doing it.
So my one suggestion is
don't feel like, I guess,
overambitious.
If you've got to get the
pre-cut, get the pre-cut.
If the pre-cut is going to make
you eat it, get the pre-cut.
Whereas we have these
grandiose ideas,
like, oh, but I
need to be doing--
but I need to actually cut it.
And then we end up buying a
bag of onions and they rot.
Because we're like, well,
I don't really want to.
Just buy the pre-chopped.
And then as far as
from the day-to-day,
if there are fruits and
vegetables that are easier,
that you're like, OK--
like a banana, for example.
Or like a Clementine,
or an orange,
or something like that,
something that is faster
and you know that.
But then also checking in with
yourself and saying, why am I--
why is this-- kind of like
sitting with that deeper
question of why am I allowing
these other things to stop me
from taking the time to do this?
And just being a little bit
more real with yourself too.
It's not an easy fix.
We're complicated.
We're these computer systems
that are very intense.
So it's just kind of always
checking in with yourself.
And I think you'll
start to realize.
And then maybe in
a month from now,
we'll see you out here, cutting
the apples and being like,
yeah, I did it.
It just takes some time.
So hopefully that answered.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LINDSEY SMITH: Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So if you're
feeling one of these emotions
you mentioned, like
sad, tired, hangry,
and you try to satiate that
emotion with the recommended
foods, and it's just
not getting there,
you're still feeling
that emotion.
What do you do?
LINDSEY SMITH: Well, I think
that there's multiple things.
So someone asked me this really
great question the other day.
It was, do you
think of your method
as prescription or preventative?
And I think that's kind of
similar to what you're saying.
I think some days, you just want
the chocolate fudge brownie.
Eat the chocolate fudge brownie.
Eat it.
And I find what happens
is, what we'll often do--
sometimes there's just--
we want that thing.
And that's OK.
It's OK to have that, and to
eat it, and feel good about it.
When you eat something
that your body--
let's just say, for
example, you really
want this chocolate
fudge brownie.
That's what your craving is.
And you're like, oh-- but
you're beating yourself
up in your head.
You're like, well, I
shouldn't have that.
I don't want that.
I shouldn't do it.
And then you're like, well,
maybe I'll just have--
then the chocolate fudge
brownies are right there.
And you're like, oh,
I'll just have one bite.
And then you're like, no.
And then your friends are
over eating carrot sticks.
You're like, why
can't I be like them?
And then it's like this whole
stressful thing in your mind.
And what you're doing
to your body, when
you stress about eating
something like that,
is physically, that stress
is no different than any type
of other stress, like if
someone's attacking you.
Your blood rushes
to your feet to run,
to your hands to
fight something off,
and to your brain to think.
So the last thing it's
thinking about doing
is digesting that
chocolate brownie
that you're stressing about.
So if you really
want something--
or then the other thing
we do is we're like,
wow, I really want
the chocolate brownie,
but I'm trying to be healthy.
So I'm going to have
some cacao nibs,
and then you eat the cacao nibs.
And you're like, but
that doesn't satisfy it.
And then you have
something kind of bitter,
so then you want
something sweet.
So then you're like,
well, now I'll have fruit.
Now I want something salty.
And then you spend all
day trying to get the--
when if you would have just
ate the chocolate brownie
and appreciated it, and
savored it, and looked at it
as something like--
I guess precious-- looked
something at it like, wow,
this is something I really
get to enjoy right now.
I'm going to savor it, I'm
going to feel good about it,
I'm going to eat it with
love, I'm going to--
really just bring
that into that.
And then you'll end
up processing it.
You'll get any nutrients that
are in that chocolate brownie.
You will get them.
And you'll also
digest it differently.
And so I think there's a
balance of something like that,
when you want a craving.
And then also thinking of
this as preventative as well.
By eating more of those
foods, it's called--
what we learned in
nutrition school,
which is called crowding out.
So if you find yourself really
struggling with depression
or anxiety, and you start
incorporating more foods,
it's not going to
happen overnight.
But over time, what happens
is the more that you
eat those foods, it naturally
crowds out the other thing.
People ask me all
the time, Lindsey,
how do you just have a piece of
dark chocolate and you're OK?
Or you don't want these things?
I don't feel like
I'm depriving myself.
But naturally, just
the way that I've--
I've been doing
this work since I
was 12 years old, since
I suffered from anxiety
and started to get help.
And the first thing I did
was go to a wellness center
in my hometown.
And through that experience,
I started learning
about health and nutrition.
And so this has been
over half my life.
And so being easy
on yourself as well,
but also looking
at it as OK, I'm
going to start
eating more of these
to naturally crowd out more
of those other cravings.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: That's
just such a fair point.
We all are constantly
beating ourselves up.
And I know you've written
quite a bit about food guilt.
LINDSEY SMITH: Um-hmm,
my whole last book.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: It
was all about food guilt.
LINDSEY SMITH: Yeah.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: But I
think since that came up,
can you talk to us a
little bit about what
you recommend for
people who are trying
to get out of that cycle?
LINDSEY SMITH: Yeah.
So I did a survey
with the Nielsen group
and found that 85% of
women and 65% of men
experience food guilt
on a daily basis.
And so I was
thinking about that.
And I'm like, going in--
what are they called, MKs?
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Um-hmm.
LINDSEY SMITH: OK,
going into the MK--
I'm learning the lingo.
Going into the MKs over there.
Or into your pantry, into your
fridge, out at a restaurant.
85% of the time,
women, specifically,
are feeling guilty, are
feeling stressed about food.
And like I said, that is
causing stress on your body.
You're not able to
digest things as well.
So part of that is being able
to go into every situation.
I always say, go into
every situation with food,
whether it's kale or a
cookie, with a sense of love
and appreciation for that.
I had a client once, and
I was teaching her this.
And the one day,
she's like, Lindsey, I
was craving a
McDonald's cheeseburger.
And I was like, OK,
what did you do?
I wanted to know.
And she was like, well,
I was beating myself up,
but I was going to
go get it anyway,
but then I was doing
that whole thing.
But then I remembered
what you said.
So I was like, OK,
I'm going to allow
myself to go there, to do this.
She was like, so I
went, I ordered it.
I was real nice to
the drive-thru people,
and I was like, thank you.
And I go and pull over.
And she's like, and I sit
there with my hamburger,
and I'm just like thinking
about the whole process
this hamburger took to get here.
I was like, wow, the
farms that had this wheat
to make this bun.
And she was like--
I mean, she was
really going for it.
And she was like, I
stopped and appreciated it.
She's like, and then
I ate the hamburger.
And she's like, and guess what?
I was like, what?
And she's like, I
didn't get sick.
She's like, normally,
I would get sick.
She's like, but I ate
a McDonald's hamburger,
and I didn't get sick.
So I'm a little worried.
What she did is she was
like, and then I did it,
and I let it go, and it
didn't sit with me for weeks.
I wasn't constantly
thinking about it.
And she's like, to be
honest, it didn't even
do what it normally did for me.
Because now I'm at the
point where I'm like,
OK, I don't feel
that like I need it
or that it's going to
provide me with something.
Because I've been able to
just see it for what it is
and not make it a
bigger production
or bring more emotional
value than what it really is.
And oftentimes, we do that,
because food is very emotional.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Yeah,
that makes a ton of sense.
Any live questions?
Yeah, go for it.
LINDSEY SMITH: More.
Woo.
AUDIENCE: So when
you have craving,
when do you know you
should go for it,
or when should you hold back?
LINDSEY SMITH: That's
a good question.
I would say, you're
probably going
to not like me for this answer.
But I would say, I think
you really have to--
that's when it comes to
listening to your body
and being able to decipher
some of the differences.
And I think it's not going
to come by being perfect.
It's going to come from giving
in to a craving and being like,
oh, I didn't feel that
great because of it.
Or it's not even giving in,
allowing yourself to go for it
and then seeing how you
feel in that moment.
And taking all of
this as information,
thinking a bit like a Google
search, except for your body.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE:
Ooh, there you go.
LINDSEY SMITH: Look at that.
I'm just really
cheesing it up today.
But thinking of it as like
a search that's like, OK,
this works or this didn't.
And asking yourself
the deeper questions,
like, OK, well, why
am I craving this?
Is there something
happening today?
What's my stress level like?
And I even map out in the
book some different questions.
Let me see where they're at--
different questions
to ask yourself
when you are feeling
like you want
to have something to really
kind of stop and ask yourself.
I can't find it right now.
But it's in here.
The other thing that I
just noticed here too, is--
I'm like, look at what
I notice in my own book.
But the other thing
that I noticed
is sometimes, part
of my method and my--
in this book, specifically--
is going deeper.
But then also saying,
OK, I'm craving sugar.
I'm craving this.
And then I have a
chart in here that says
what your body may really need.
And so you'll be able
to start putting--
it's like putting the
puzzle pieces together.
You do the searches and
then you start mapping out.
And you're like, oh, so for
me, if I'm craving a burger,
I know that it's probably
that time, people, and my iron
is getting low, and that's
just what my body needs.
And so I know how
to fuel it properly.
But it didn't always
come that way.
So I think that can help.
AUDIENCE: What's your approach
to influencing your friends
and family to eat healthier
without becoming that person?
LINDSEY SMITH: Ooh!
Girl.
So my approach is just
having empathy for people,
trying to meet people
where they're at.
When my dad got sick in 2000--
2010, I believe,
I was like, Dad,
we need to be
doing ginger shots.
And I was telling
him all these things.
And what I realized
is that I had
to meet him where he was at.
He was a drinker, and a
smoker, and loves McDonald's.
I'm not going to--
this man is not going to
start doing ginger shots.
So then what I did is I
met him where he was at.
I was like, Dad, I bet you
can't do this ginger shot.
Since he was a
drinker, I was like--
I like masked them
and was like, I
bet this would be
too strong for you.
I know you're a vodka guy.
But this ginger is even
stronger than vodka, Dad.
And so it became kind of a joke.
But I think meeting
people where they're at.
I think one of the
things that I try to do
is just have that empathy for
people and try to foster that.
Because I have never
really met anyone
that got healthier
because of judgments.
And if anything, it leads
to horrible eating cycles
over time.
So something that
I try to do is just
be the example myself
and bring things.
Bring a certain salad, or
a certain dish, or a bread,
and let them try it.
And my mom had never
tried hummus before.
And I brought it.
And now she's like, oh--
sorry.
I'm from Pittsburgh, so
when I talk about my parents
I do the Yinzer accent.
And it just almost came out.
Because we call ourselves--
people say yinz instead of you
guys or y'all.
We say yinz.
So my mom's like,
oh, I just loved it.
Oh, I just loved that
hummus that yinz got.
That's how they talk.
And then my father-in-law
the one day--
he knows that I'm in this.
And this was so sweet.
He was like, Linds,
I got that quinoa
that you were talking about.
And I was like, you mean quinoa?
But it showed that
they were interested.
And it was because this
is the way that I live.
And I'm not going to
try to change you,
but I will bring
something so that you
can try it and enjoy it too.
And so I think, with that, I've
seen changes in my own family
members through just
leading by example
and not being judgmental.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE:
That's huge.
I love your point about
people don't change
because they feel judged.
They're going to change when
they're ready to change.
LINDSEY SMITH: Absolutely.
And when I was the judgmental
person, everyone just hated me.
In fact, my friends
have a running joke.
They were like, yeah,
remember that period
where we all stopped
talking to you.
I'm like, those are great times.
I was like, but at
least I had kale.
it's just because that's
just not how we thrive.
Now, some people maybe.
But I doubt it.
It's probably a very
small percentage.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE:
Yeah, I would say so.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question.
For all these fad
diets, which ones do you
find the most misleading or--
dangerous is too
extreme of a word--
and which ones do you see as
healthier options and ones
that you can incorporate along
with your daily nutrition?
LINDSEY SMITH: Yeah.
That's a good question.
I think that the ones that
I hate the most personally
are the click bait
things that are like,
the five fruits that
are ruining your life.
And I'm like, but it's fruit.
You know, there's like,
why you should never
have a banana ever again.
And I'm like, but it's a fruit.
And I think that
that's where it comes
to listening to your body,
because then-- some people,
yeah, a banana is great.
Some people-- it may
not sit well with you.
So those are the ones
that I don't like.
If anything is too restrictive,
over time, it's not feasible.
So if something is too--
I know a lot of people--
some of these people are
my friends that have these,
so I don't want
to call them out.
But there's certain
trends, there's certain--
like diet programs that
come around every year.
And I think the
problem with them
is that they're so
restrictive that long term,
it's hard for that to
become a lifestyle.
Because then we carry
the guilt in it.
We're like, well,
I'm not doing--
oh, I want grains now, or
I want something now, then.
And I can't have it.
So I think that.
I think the biggest thing
is more plant based.
We can all afford to
eat more plant based.
I think that's one thing
that I can get behind,
just because we should
all be eating more fruits
or vegetables anyway.
So incorporating more
plant based foods
into your lifestyle, I think, is
one that'll never really go out
of style because of that.
But it really just
comes down to listening.
Because you can do any of those
types of diets and see what
feels best for you.
So if you're doing paleo,
that may work really well,
and you may say yes.
And it can change.
I didn't eat poultry
for 10 years.
And this past September,
all in one day,
I was like, I just need a
whole chicken right now.
And I don't know.
And you know what?
It was my collagen.
I needed more
collagen in my joints.
And I was eating chicken,
and I was like, fine.
My joints felt so much better.
And so it can change.
And being open to that, and
taking what you learn from it,
and going from there.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE:
So I have a question.
LINDSEY SMITH: Yes.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: I work
with a lot of women who suffer
or have suffered from
eating disorders.
So listening to their bodies
is really, really hard.
What recommendations
do you have for people
who are just getting
started on that journey
and maybe don't even
know what that means?
LINDSEY SMITH: I think
paying attention.
And I also think
finding support,
you know, like
someone like yourself,
or just being able to
have someone that you
can talk to about these things.
Because I think sometimes
talking through things
can help you realize,
oh, yeah, this
is why I did this or
this is why I did that.
And being able to have that
kind of sounding board, I think,
is really important.
And then I think for anyone
just starting with the basics,
doing one thing a week for
yourself and your health.
So many times we're like, I'm
going to the grocery store.
I'm getting all the
fruits and vegetables.
I have meal plans for days.
I've got breakfast, lunch,
and dinner planned out.
And then by Wednesday,
you're like,
oh, I just want a burger
from the local joint
down the street.
Or half your groceries
just end up sitting there.
You don't eat them because it's
not what your body is really
wanting.
And so instead of going
all in, I just tell people,
hey, do one thing a week.
Drink more water.
It's simple.
We don't do it, include myself.
I'm like, I need to start
hydrating this trip.
But just doing simple things.
And over time, it just
becomes part of who you are.
And then the awareness.
Because some people are at a
point where, like you said,
they're so conflicted
with all these things.
The other day I went
in a grocery store,
and there was half
the fat avocados.
I was like, what?
That's how they
were marketing them.
And I'm like, half
the fat avoc--
just eat the avocado.
And all it was was an
avocado cut in half.
That's all it was.
It was just packaged like that,
like it's now half the fat.
I'm like, yeah, I can go get
one off the bin over here
for $3 less.
But being bombarded with
that stuff all the time,
especially with an
eating disorder,
can be very sensitive.
And so I think seeking support
and then starting small
and being OK with yourself--
or not OK with yourself,
but being OK with
starting small.
Because it's hard
for a lot of people.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE:
Yeah, thank you.
We have another live question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
LINDSEY SMITH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
suggestions for situations
where you can't really
control your food?
I'm also from Pennsylvania.
So when I go home, it's like--
LINDSEY SMITH: What part?
AUDIENCE: Northeast.
Scranton.
LINDSEY SMITH: Oh, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So my mom
will be like, hey,
I know you like
avocado and kale now.
But here she bakes a pizza and a
dozen cupcakes for the two days
you are here.
LINDSEY SMITH: So a couple
of my own personal tricks.
I don't know if this
will work for you.
But I just tend to
bring snacks and bring--
so if I was going home,
I'd be like, oh, I'm
going to stop and
get some whatever.
And then you'd get something
healthy and bring it to share.
I'm always big into like
bringing things to share,
and selfishly, because
I want to know what
I'm walking into a little bit.
And also, if there's something
that you want when you're home
or where it's hard,
I think it's just
going back to being mindful
of not beating yourself up
being like OK, this is
two days we're here.
I brought these
snacks, and we're good.
But I know my mom really wants
to go to this pizza joint
because it means a lot to her.
And this is her way
of showing love,
so I'm going to just
appreciate it for what it is.
And being kind of a little
bit easy on yourself.
And I think that'll
help you actually feel--
you'll probably feel
less anxious going home.
Because you probably already
pre-worry about that before you
go home.
So I think that'll help you
ease into it a little bit more.
And just give yourself some
grace and empathy as well.
Because we tend to just beat
ourselves up before anything.
We pre-worry about food
more than I have ever.
And even myself,
I'm like, oh, am I
going to know what I
eat when I get there?
It's like this thing.
But I think controlling what you
can, but then giving yourself
grace moving forward,
if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Any
other live questions?
Otherwise, we have
a few minutes,
and I want to tackle
one more Dory question.
So I love the question
about anxiety.
So what other things did you do
to help overcome your anxiety?
And if you still get anxious
today, how do you cope with it?
LINDSEY SMITH: Yes.
So I definitely
still get anxious.
I'm not perfect.
One of the things
when I was a kid--
and I don't think
I mentioned this--
but I suffered from anxiety.
I was hospitalized.
And I was kind of
intuitive as a kid,
and I think which leads to the
approach that I take today,
because I've tapped into that.
But I said to my parents,
I was like, you know what?
I don't want to
continue this way.
This is not being--
going to the hospital,
like all this, this isn't--
I don't want to do this.
So do you think I
could try something?
Could I get therapy?
So my parents were like,
yeah, cool, whatever.
We'll take you to therapy.
I'm like, great.
They've never been to
therapy in their life,
but they're like,
sure, whatever,
which I was grateful for.
So I started going to
therapy, and it was OK.
But my therapist was old school,
so it was very straightforward,
like OK.
And as you can tell, I'm wearing
a fruit and veggies suit.
I like to keep it
a little bit real.
My sister's eight
years older than me.
And she started going
to this wellness center,
and I saw a shift in her.
We suffered from similar things.
And I said, hey, can
I try that instead?
So they were like, sure, great.
So I started going to
this wellness center.
And we really focused
on eating mindfulness.
He taught me Tai chi,
actually, as a 12-year-old.
Yeah, I know.
Acupuncture-- I was
doing all of it.
And those things
really helped me.
And by ninth grade,
I was actually
teaching stress management
workshops to my student council
conferences.
Because I learned all
these different tools.
So I definitely think
that food is a part of it.
I know what foods can trigger
me and can trigger anxiety
within me.
But then sometimes,
I get anxiety.
And I'm like, I
didn't eat anything,
I don't even feel
stressed in my mind.
But my body is anxious.
And so for me, a lot of times
it has to do with taking less
screen time-- which I know is
not something Googlers want
to hear--
or just allowing
myself to veg out.
Because so many times, I'm
one of those people that I
like to feel accomplished,
and to be doing something,
and always have a
project to be working on,
to go forward on something,
but allowing that downtime.
And through that, I feel
like I have a toolbox,
and I can be like, OK,
well, let's try this thing.
This doesn't work?
OK, let's try this.
And so I have some different
resources like that,
like meditation or
lessening the screen time,
and making room for fun.
I didn't do that for years,
where I just was like, oh, I've
got to grind, got to do this.
And I wouldn't even
allow myself to have
fun in situations
that should be fun
because I'd always be
thinking about the things
that I needed to do.
So making sure that you have
and allow time to just play,
and have fun, and be silly,
and act like a little kid.
Sometimes I do that.
I'm ready to ride
those bikes after this.
I'm like, form my little
bike crew or whatever,
just ride around Google.
Just stuff like that.
Silly, but it's fun.
And it gets you out of
the stress sometimes.
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Awesome.
Well, thank you, Lindsey.
We're so glad that you
were able to join us
and will now stick around for
questions and to give everybody
their book.
LINDSEY SMITH: Yeah, woo!
KATHERINE EDGECUMBE: Thank you.
LINDSEY SMITH: Yay, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]